so wie dramatisch die ganze lage ist das
zeigt auch der aktuelle flight radar da
sieht man nämlich nicht nur der luftraum
über der ukraine ist inzwischen komplett
gesperrt die lufthansa hat sich nun auch
dazu entschlossen russisches
hoheitsgebiete komplett zu meiden wie
die aktuelle situation der truppen jetzt
aussieht vor ort das wollen wir uns
jetzt mal von unseren militärexperten
max kiewel und wir uns stritzel erklären
lassen
[Musik]
wir erleben den vierten tag dieser
blutigen offensive wieder schlagen die
truppen von wladimir putin blutig zu
aber und das ist vielleicht an diesem
tag nach dieser nacht eine interessante
entwicklung die ukraine die schlagen
sich mutiger heldenhafter als das viele
erwartet haben und vor allem auch
wahrscheinlich als dass wladimir putin
erwartet hat beim millionenspritze unser
chefkorrespondent für die außenpolitik
hören wo stehen wir an diesem tag wohin
müssen wir schauen um zu verstehen wie
sich der krieg in der ukraine entwickelt
du hast ja die die wichtigsten orte
schon schon eingezeichnet in der karte
also wir haben ja eben von unserem
unseren korrespondenten von unseren
reportern aus kiew gehört das ist
natürlich mit abstand das wichtigste
ziel der russischen armee die
ukrainische hauptstadt nicht nur weniger
symbolwirkung sondern natürlich auch was
ich dort die politische führung des
landes aufhält und weil sich dort eben
auch ein ein großer teil der bevölkerung
ein großer teil der bevölkerung aufhält
und es ist tatsächlich so dass wir da
zwar schon schwere kämpfe gesehen haben
im vorfeld sozusagen in vororten von
kiew allerdings die stadt selber bisher
noch vom krieg relativ verschont
geblieben ist also wir haben noch keine
keine schwere artillerie wir haben keine
schweren keine schweren luftschläge
gesehen auf die stadt ich will das gar
nicht verharmlosen was da bisher schon
geschehen ist aber wenn wir uns
anschauen wie die russischen
streitkräfte in anderen städten
großstädten vorgegangen sind so wenn wir
uns erinnern an großen nie wie das außer
nach fünf wochen anfang der 2000er oder
auch aleppo wo tatsächlich also urbane
zentren komplett eingeäschert wurden
dann ist das was da jetzt passiert es
bisher noch vergleichsweise
vergleichsweise gering wir erleben
zwei formen eigentlich vielleicht des
angriffs aus kiew wir haben diese
truppen bewegung von oben aus
weißrussland aus dem norden gesehen und
dann hat einen flug fällt auf dass wir
nachher noch mal schauen werden genau
eine rolle gespielt da brückenkopf wo
man vielleicht versucht hat dieses
flugfeld zu erobern und dann eben
schnell nachschub schnelle auch
besondere kräfte an den ort bekommen zu
können eine andere stadt die gerade an
diesem tag beginnt eine ganz große rolle
zu spielen die liegt hier was ist das
für eine stadt und warum ist sie so
wichtig also dafür ist ja dass die
zweitgrößte stadt der ukraine hat
millionen einwohner liegt natürlich auch
unmittelbar an der grenze und die haben
da in den wochen monaten zuvor auch auf
der russischen seite einen der größten
truppenaufmarsch einen der größten
truppen konzentration gesehen das heißt
die einnahme einnahme einer solchen
großstadt in solch einen zweiten
wichtigen bevölkerung und industrie
zentrums hat natürlich schon einmal
auswirkungen auf die wirtschaft der
ukraine und zum anderen eben ist das
auch ein wichtiger knotenpunkt verkehrs
punkt logistisch ist das natürlich wenn
solchen vormarsch wenn eine solche
einnahme enorm wichtig wenn man solche
großstadt ein solches verkehrszentrum
unter kontrolle wir sind ja hier auch
tatsächlich also von caracas laufen die
wesentlichen verkehrsachsen des landes
weiter in richtung westen straßen die
man natürlich braucht wenn man mit
schwerem gerät unterwegs ist und eben an
diesem morgen erreichen uns da die
ersten bilder aus der stadt dass dort
russische truppen unterwegs sind noch
lässt sich nicht absehen wie viele und
wo genau aber dass da zumindest doch ein
äußerer verteidigungsring womöglich
gebrochen und überwunden wurde der in
den letzten tagen noch gehalten hat da
hat es tatsächlich sehr schwere kämpfe
gegeben an eines einzelnen frontmann
einzelnen vororten also wir haben videos
gesehen wo wo russische mehrfach
raketenwerfer tatsächlich die front oder
massives feuer gelegt haben also
insofern das war tatsächlich der der ort
wo wahrscheinlich zumindest gestern
nacht am stärksten gekämpft oder
massivsten gekämpft wurde und ich bin
mir auch nicht sicher wie lange die
ukrainische front da halten wird in
anderen unverhältnismäßig großen gelände
gewinn haben wir in den letzten tagen
hier unten im süden gesehen da ist man
von hier unten vorgedrungen und hat auch
eben in milito pohl ja die erste große
stadt erobern können wir wollen mal
schauen wir haben bilder aus dieser
stadt wo man eben sieht wie das dann
aussieht wenn eben die zivilbevölkerung
aus dem fenster guckt und dann sieht man
plötzlich oh mann da laufen russische
soldaten durch meine stadt durch meine
straße ein größerer konvoi eine größere
patrouille von eben russischen soldaten
die hier patroullieren auf der straße
wären das bedeutet diese markierung hier
die wir die wir da immer wieder sehen
auf den fahrzeugen genau dieses zeit
also als taktisches zeichen sozusagen
das zum einen
wahrscheinlich zur freund feind
unterscheidung üblicherweise haben ja
wir sehen ja da zwei streitkräfte
aufeinandertreffen die ukrainische und
russische armee die in vielen
waffensystemen ähnliche waffensystemen
aus der sowjetunion die gleichen sachen
systeme besitzen in dem fall war es
tatsächlich ein anderes sind die wir im
rap der der russischen streitkräfte also
ein gepanzertes fahrzeug
dass tatsächlich nur die russischen
streitkräfte haben aber das
wahrscheinlich auch als taktisches
zeichner zuordnungen als zuordnung der
fungiert das alles sind für die
russische seite gute nachrichten aber
ich habe es vorhin gesagt es gibt eben
auch andere bilder und die werden mehr
und mehr und die erreichen uns mehr und
mehr und die sprechen für ein anderes
bild das ja zum beispiel ein russischer
konvoi am straßenrand der wenn wir ihnen
einmal vielleicht groß einblenden können
ja für große zerstörung spricht und
dafür eben spricht dass die russen und
die russischen streitkräfte am ende
nicht so durch das land kommt vordringen
können wie das virus selbst gedacht und
geplant haben genau wir haben die
markierungen auch wieder gesehen diese z
förmig den markierungen und die tatsache
dass dann so solch riesiger konvoi
beschossen wurde also mutmaßlich
sieht alles danach aus dass eine
luftangriffe wahrscheinlich ukrainische
erdkampfflugzeuge es 25 das spricht
dafür dass die dass die russischen
streitkräfte immer noch nicht
ansatzweise lufthoheit haben man hat ja
erwartet dass das nach dem nach den
ersten luftschlägen haben wir auch
gesehen mit marschflugkörpern zu beginn
des angriffs das sozusagen die
russischen die ukrainischen flug
flugfähigkeiten stark eingeschränkt
dezimiert werden ist wahrscheinlich auch
der fall gewesen aber eben nicht
komplett wir sehen dass hier dass ein
solcher konvoi zerstört werden kann aus
der luft sehr wahrscheinlich aus der
luft das spricht eben noch nicht dafür
dass selbst in mehr als 72 stunden nach
beginn des angriffs die ukrainer immer
noch solche fähigkeiten verfügen und ist
aus russischer sicht natürlich ein
absoluter albtraum denn das an den
eigener konvoi mit so vielen fahrzeugen
wir sehen ja auch viele logistik
fahrzeuge am anfang sind wahrscheinlich
franken brückenbauer also alles logistik
die man braucht um weiter vorzukommen im
land so aufgerieben so zerstört wird
schutzlos ausgeliefert ist da offenbar
der ukrainischen luftwaffe
er spricht dann doch dafür dass da ganz
viel auch auf taktischer ebene womöglich
noch nicht so funktioniert wie sie sich
das selbst erhofft haben ganz offenbar
also das mitunter das zusammenspiel
wahrscheinlich auch noch nicht eingeübt
zwischen einzelnen
zwischen einzelnen teile
teilen dieser dieser invasion
streitmacht wir haben es auch gesehen
dass einzelne deutlich gibt es häufig
dann hat in so einem in solchen
kriegsszenarien dass einzelne einheiten
jahr abgeschnitten werden schneller
vorrücken als andere beziehungsweise
langsamer aber in unserem fall dass das
tatsächlich die logistik dann
nachschublinien getroffen werden das ist
natürlich katastrophal wir haben es auch
in anderen videos gesehen dass daneben
die folge solcher solcher ja
abgeschnitten nachschubrouten das dann
russische streitkräfte mitunter auch
kampfpanzer liegen bleiben weiterhin
genauso oder was wir eben auch sehen ist
das ein unglaubliches video das eben im
ja einzelnen ukrainischen soldaten ist
gelingt mit modernen gelieferten
panzerabwehrwaffen ganze russische
konvois mit panzern zu zerstören was
sind das für waffen und warum sind die
so mächtig was was was passiert da was
gelingt da
also wir haben ja diesen genau den
herren darin vorgesehene relativ relativ
entspannt mit seiner panzerabwehrwaffe
rumläuft das müsste eine von den
schwedisch beziehungsweise britischen
android sein also eine panzerabwehrwaffe
die
fähigkeit hat auf eine relativ große
reichweite auch panzer zu bekämpfen
manchmal so guten halben kilometer die
auch ein such kopf hat wir haben gelenkt
linken such kopf hat und offensichtlich
sehr effektiv ist was allerdings was ich
auch bemerkenswert finde bisher in
diesem haben es ja schon gesehen einige
gepanzerte fahrzeuge und panzer die in
unterschiedlichen orten zerstört wurden
dem keiner ist bisher die fähigkeit der
ukrainischen armee videos von diesen
einsätzen relativ relativ unter
verschluss zu halten weekends in anderen
kriegsszenarien da sind ständig
abschlüsse von ständig abschlüsse von
solchen panzerabwehrwaffen auf die
fahrzeuge zu verzeichnen
das ist hier nicht der fall also ist ein
sehr gute disziplin offensichtlich waren
nicht alle videos sofort raus zu hauen
und
und zu zeigen wie man eben da die
russischen panzer beschossen hat auch
aus genau hauptsächlich natürlich aus
sicherheitspolitischen gründen genau um
den russen nichts zu verraten zum
abschluss vielleicht noch einmal in
diesem konflikt den sieht man eben auch
mittlerweile ja aus dem weltall
satellitenbilder hier die uns von diesem
flugfeld wir haben vorhin drüber
gesprochen aus dem nordwesten von kiew
erreichen und auf diesem flug fällt das
sieht man hier der wird nach wie vor
erbittert gekämpft und das sind voller
feuer die man sieht auch hier unten in
der ecke wo brände ausgebrochen sind wo
vielleicht munitionsdepots kerosin tanks
in die luft geflogen sind und was eben
zeigt dass der kampf um kiew noch voll
im gange also wenn sozusagen genau die
einnahme das hatte das war ja am ersten
tag des in der inversion auch der
offensichtlich der russische planen dass
man sozusagen die diese flughäfen um
kiew möglichst schnell einnimmt dass man
dann auch einen brückenkopf schlagen
kann dass man dann luftlandetruppen
reinbringt die auch leicht gepanzerte
fahrzeuge dann sehr schnell einsetzen
können und das hat ja nicht geklappt die
ukrainische seite haben das ja
zurückgeschlagen diesen angriff und man
hat eben dann tatsächlich auch noch die
ja diese flughäfen immer noch nicht
unter kontrolle
deutlich vom kiefer muss jetzt darauf
hoffen dass man oder wartet dann
sozusagen aber mit mit der langsamer
einrückenden haupt streitmacht die dann
halt auch aus schweren kampfpanzern
besteht um endlich diese diese flughäfen
einzunehmen und daneben die schachtel
kiew beginnen zu können die schlacht um
tiere werden sehen wie sich die
entwickelt halten aber fest die ukraine
schlagen sich wacker und tapferer und
mutiger als das zumindest vielleicht
mehr putin sicherlich erwartet hat das
schon ich würde allerdings noch
einwerfen dass das natürlich trotzdem
also bei allem bei allem bei einer
tapferkeit den heldenmut in mukran an
den tag legen muss man immer noch
bedenken die sind natürlich trotzdem
deutlich schlechter ausgerüstet sind
zahlenmäßig den russischen streitkräften
also zumindest was die anzahl der
soldaten angeht ja doch irgendwann
unterlegen und insofern das ist also das
ist nichts das man da sagen kann dass
diese schlacht ist sozusagen schon
entschieden oder hätte sich aufgrund der
schlechten moral der russischen truppen
die sicherlich ist vorhanden das
wiedersehen aus auf den videos also das
ist sozusagen ein selbstläufer werde
dass es bei weitem nicht vielen dank für
deine analyse